the reason I put so much time and effort
into creating Tesla was because it it
seemed to me that the transportation
will go electric and should go electric
but we have a nun priced externality in
the negative effects of of gasoline and
on the environment and also in the you
know the wars that we fight and national
security and that kind of thing whenever
you have a nun price externality you
can't quite review can quite rely on the
market to to do the right thing so in
order to have electric vehicles come
sooner than the otherwise would really
electric vehicles were always going to
be the long-term transportation
mechanism but to make that day come
sooner
you have to bridge the gap with
innovation that was the goal with Tesla
is to try to serve as a catalyst to
accelerate the day the day of electric
vehicles and and I I think when all said
and done I'm hopeful that historians
will look back on Tesla and say the
Tesla advanced that by at least ten
years which that would be a huge victory
in my in my mind the Solar City of
course is on the soul it is on the
energy production side of things because
it doesn't help if we have sustainable
consumption of energy but but then that
energy isn't produced in a sustainable
way and I feel quite strongly that solar
power will be the single largest source
of of electricity generation by the
midpoint of the century infected just a
simple extrapolation of the growth of
solar power would show that that's
obviously going to be the case and also
when you consider that the earth is
almost entirely solar-powered today and
that the the fact that we're not a
frozen ice ball at say 4 degrees Kelvin
and it is just due to the Sun and the
whole ecosystem is powered by the Sun
there's just an any bitty amount of
energy that we need to do complicated
human things this is a tiny
out of energy really compared to what
the Sun puts on the earth every day and
we just need to capture a little bit of
that and turn it into electricity so we
have to try to accelerate that with
innovation that's what solar studies
about